- Alright, so let's check out this bidet.
Uh-huh, what's this down thing?
- [Ella] Don't squire me in the face!
(water splashing)
(laughter)
- Oh, no!
- [Ella] For one week, we tried the Tushy,
a bidet you can install
on most any toilet.
Bidets are used around the world
but are not very common in America.
A bidet uses water to clean
your genitals and butt,
reducing or eliminating
the need for toilet paper.
Many claim it's a cleaner,
greener way to go.
It's basically a device that squirts water
at your butt.
- I know they exist.
I didn't really have an
interest in using one.
- It's called Tushy!
Tushy, cool!
- Alright, you got to connect
some things to the water.
That seems reasonable enough.
- I haven't really been known
to be good at installing things.
- Wow, freedom, Tushy helps prevent UTIs,
hemorrhoids, skid marks and dingleberries.
(laughing)
- Who's got
a dingleberry problem?
- What's this now?
- A towel?
Why can't, can I just wipe
my butt with toilet paper?
- This is not something people do, right?
I don't wanna have a butt towel.
- I'm gonna try it.
- Well, I'm really excited
about this, aside from this.
I will air dry.
- We're trying to install the Tushy.
We never got a wrench,
we're gonna make do.
- We don't need a wrench at all.
- Day two of the 10-minute set-up.
- Start on step one, shall we?
I don't know which way is off.
- 10 minute install, my ass!
- (groaning) Oh, God!
I think the water pressure's too high.
I feel bad for everyone that doesn't
have a Hannah in their life to do this.
- Oh, my God! (moaning)
- We have a bidet.
Are you happy?
- We were able to get a
wrench from a neighbor
and I'm going to give it a whirl.
- See how the home install
compares to my work.
- Oh, God, (whispering) I'm nervous.
(shocking inhales)
(laughter)
It just cleans your butt.
- Fresh butt.
- Definitely powerful ...
and cold ... but I'm into it.
Let's see how this week goes.
- I could not use it without laughing.
It's just so funny to me.
- There's a bit of a
learning curve to the Tushy.
(water splashing)
A reposition.
Okay, I think I figured it out.
I don't like it still.
(water splashing)
- I mean I don't hate it.
It's fun, it's like I
wake up in the morning and
nothing like having a spray
of ice cold water up my butt.
- I was able to suspend
reality for a little bit
being, like, it's not
toilet water that shooting
at my butthole, but it is.
A Tushy ... we have a
weird ... look at it.
A weird relationship
right now, to be honest,
and I just don't now if
I want to continue it.
- This is what I've
always wanted in my life.
It's like, I feel luxurious.
- I am happy that I have
a bidet in my home now
just for those spicy days.
You know, sometimes you
eat like a Chipotle burrito
and you ask for hot salsa
and then later you regret it.
- Yeah, I was really into until I tried it
and then I was like,
this doesn't feel great,
and I was like, but it's practical.
Now I'm like, mm, I could live without it.
- Pretty life-changing, pretty great.
Question: do you do this when you pee?
Answer in the comments below.